l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison ce sommet international
est selon vous constituez véritablement
une étape décisive pour la transition
politique en libye
oui cette réunion de berlin qui
d'ailleurs était assez court s'il ya pas
grand chose à négocier a rendu tout à
fait sensible le fait qu'un processus de
paix était en cours et qu'il progressait
sous l'égide des nations unies
ce processus avance à son rythme il est
très complexe parce que la situation en
libye est très complexe et on a vu
l'année dernière la recherche d'un
cessez le feu qui avait été conclu en
juillet et qui finalement n'a été signé
par toutes les parties qu'au mois
d'octobre
on a vu aussi ce processus tout à fait
particulier soixante quinze
personnalités éminentes libyennes ont
été en siégé ensemble à genève pendant
plusieurs jours pour désigner ce premier
ministre du gouvernement unifié de
transition ainsi que trois personnes
d'un conseil de l'état libyen qui est
notamment responsable de toutes les
questions de sécurité
ce processus fonctionne puisque ce
gouvernement unifié de transition a été
installé au mois de mars et que le
premier ministre a fait plusieurs
voyages dont un voyage à paris un voyage
à rome et qu'aujourd'hui l'état à berlin
alors les deux questions qui étaient sur
la table à vers là aujourd'hui
c'était le retrait des troupes
étrangères qu'il s'agisse de troupes
régulières et oyonnax notamment aux
turcs ou de mercenaires et il y en a
aussi de diverses origines et la
ministre des affaires étrangères du
gouvernement unifié de transition
rejoindre a remarqué en libye une
ministre des affaires étrangères ça
n'est pas rien déjà comme résultat a
indiqué que des contacts avaient lieu
notamment entre les turcs et les russes
pour que les milices
cyrielle qui avaient été amenés et l'on
certaines combattez d'un côté d'autres
de l'autre soit retirée peut-être 300 de
chaque côté dans les prochains jours
dans quelque chose est en train de se
passer
mais on dit qu'il y a probablement 20
mille combattants étrangers miliciens
étrangers sur le sol libyen et il faut
qu'il parte ce sera difficile puisque
l'ancien gouvernement soutenu par l'onu
n'avait dû son salut en réalité qu'à
l'intervention de la turquie puisque le
maréchal haftar avait failli prendre
tripoli en 2019 2020
le deuxième sujet qui a été évoquée
aujourd'hui c'est en effet c'était luc
l'élection élections présidentielles
élections législatives le 24 décembre
prochain certains trouvent que c'est un
peu tôt en tout cas il y a eu unanimité
aujourd'hui pour maintenir cette date
ces dates objectif le 24 décembre
prochain
c'est très important parce que dix ans
après la chute du régime de kadhafi
je crois que la population les bienne
aspire à aspire à la paix alors malgré
tout que le blanchemaison quels sont les
obstacles sont nombreux j'imagine qu'il
subsiste effectivement il y en a
beaucoup
il viendra d'obstacles juridiques qui
est que un autre comité à rédiger une
constitution une nouvelle constitution
pour la libye
mais cette constitution il faut les
soumettre à référendum et jusqu'à
présent on ne sait pas très bien quand
elle sera soumise à référendum
peut-être d'ailleurs le 24 décembre en
même temps que l'élection présidentielle
est l'initiative est un peu curieux
d'avoir des élections et de ne pas avoir
la constitution la règle du jeu
auparavant la deuxième difficulté elle
et elle est politique c'est que le
premier ministre de transition trouve
peut-être que les lettres un peu court
jusqu'au 24 décembre puisqu'en principe
et il ne se présentera pas à l'élection
du 24 et aux élections du 24 décembre
et puis la difficulté elle l est aussi
de nature sécuritaire le maréchal haftar
il y a quatre jours était à la tête de
2000 véhicules dans le sud du fezzan
parce que il y avait semble-t-il des
terroristes qui se manifestait au sud de
la libye
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas étonnant
puisque le sud de la libye est une zone
de non droit et que c'est probablement
de là que venait les adversaires du
président idriss deby qui ont tué le
président idriss deby dans le nord du
tchad
enfin il ya aussi des problèmes
d'organisation de ces élections qui
reviennent naturellement au gouvernement
de transition mais qui pose des
problèmes considérables et puis il ya
évidemment le fait que les pays
extérieurs peuvent aussi avoir leur idée
sur qui sera président de la république
sur qui sera premier ministre et qu'il
dit interviennent en coulisses pour
faire progresser telle ou telle
candidature pour le moment il y a quatre
candidats mais il y en aura certainement
plus dont d'ailleurs un des fils de
kadhafi
et puis un personnage qui a été ministre
de l'intérieur très puissants jusqu'à la
prise de fonction du gouvernement de
transition
et puis le maréchal haftar lui-même qui
sera très probablement candidat ni
lorente dans tout ça claude blanche
maison et bien l'europe qui étaient
présentes naturellement à cette réunion
de berlin comme elle était présente à la
première réunion de berlin il ya 18 mois
époque où il n'y avait pas de
gouvernement de transition époque où on
était un petit peu nulle part l'europe
attache une très grande importance à
avoir un interlocuteur stable à tripoli
parce que la libye est la voisine de
l'europe et que beaucoup de migrants
parts sur la mer méditerranée des côtes
libyennes et se dirige dans des
conditions de précarité tout à fait
scandaleuse vers l'italie alors il ya
des accords entre l'union européenne
la libye entre l'italie et la libye pour
former les garde-côtes libyens et pour
qui les empêchent de partir tous ces
migrants qui en réalité sont pris en
main par des passeurs par des mafias de
passeurs qui prennent des sommes
considérables pour mettre ces migrants
qui viennent parfois d'ailleurs de la
zone sahélienne sur des esquifs et les
lancers vers la méditerranée bien
souvent vers la mort donc pour l'union
européenne c'est un enjeu très important
que de pouvoir maîtriser ces flux de
migrants en traitant avec un
gouvernement
les biens qui sera un gouvernement
stable est là pour ça des moyens
importants notamment des moyens de
coopération des moyens de formation
et puis l' agence frontex dont c'est
aussi la mission
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous